hey guys so today I thought I'd make a
quick video just discussing how many
storylines season 5 is likely going to
cover as it seems to be a bit of
confusion on this area and I won't go
into spoilers or anything but I will
give a very generic overview of what we
can expect and what I think the pacing
is going to be like but before we get
into it don't forget to sub to the
channel if you haven't already -
celebrating 60,000 I'll be doing a video
in like 2 to 4 weeks
breaking down exactly how I make videos
so stick around for that anyway season 4
of my year academia tackled three major
storylines which were the overall arc
the cultural festival and the majority
of the pro-hero arc we also got a couple
of lighthearted episodes on the remedial
course as well now the season started
with an anime original filler and the
remaining 24 episodes proceeded to cover
chapters 125 to 190 although
interestingly the finale of season 4
does not actually finish chapter 190 so
there's still actually some things to
resolve there what this means is that
season 4 covered nearly 65 whole
chapters of the manga adapted across the
24 episodes that weren't the anime
original episode
now if season 5 was to adapt the same
amount this would take us all the way up
to chapter 255 meaning that a lot of
story arcs are about to be covered but I
know what you're thinking what exactly
are they about well season 5 will likely
begin with again another kind of filler
episode as it seems to be tradition at
this point but the episode after that
will adapt the rest of chapter 190 and
will finish off the pro hero arc in a
very interesting way it will then
continue on to the aftermath of deku
dream which we actually already saw
during the post-credits of season 4
after this we'll go into the joint
training arc which will reintroduce us
to some old faces that we haven't seen
for a long time and also show us the
potential of characters who have so far
just been background extras this arc
will show us how much the students have
improved since the sports festival and
it will also include some
never-before-seen quirks and super moves
in addition to that it will expand our
understanding of one for all and the
vestiges the joint training arc ends
around chapter 217 of the manga so using
my bad math it should cover about eight
point five chapters on paper but because
the arc is heavily centered around
fighting it will likely wrap up even
sooner than that as when the fights are
animated they typically move at quite a
fast pace at the very least they did in
season four so my guesstimate would be
six to seven episodes on the joint
training arc but moving on from that
the Mehta Liberation Army Hawk will
follow this and this storyline is
usually referred to as might within
academia this is the first arc of this
series framed entirely from the villains
perspective and it gives us a lot of
good material I'm talking in backstories
character growth quirk awakenings and
like whole new organizations that will
be super important going forward this is
without a doubt one of my favorite arcs
in the entire series and I actually did
a recap of the entire thing on YouTube
so if you're impatient like me and want
to know what happens then do go check
that out in the manga it spans from
chapters 218 to 240 so yeah it's got a
lot of content to it
I also anticipate that during the anime
they'll probably add certain battles
that weren't fully fleshed out or even
concluded in the manga like there were
certain things that one rounded out
properly so I reckon the anime will do
them a bit more justice probably using
my rough estimation my villain academia
should roughly be around nine episodes
and if that is the case then it would
give us around eight episodes for the
remainder of season five but this all
depends on how they want to pace
everything of course and following this
will have the Endeavour agency arc now
this will show us why endeavour is like
the best mentor ever and it also gives
us a bit of insight into how he intends
to atone for what he did to Shoto and
Rey and you know the rest of the family
and it gives us a little bit of insight
into the history of the Taraki family
and also you know endeavor certain
things from his past art to catch up
with him so yeah it's really interesting
and this arc is about eleven chapters so
roughly the same lot as the pro hero arc
much like season two I reckon there will
be a filler episode that will show us
what students are up to during their
various internships so that could take
up an additional episode if they decide
to do it because of that I expect this
whole situation to be wrapped up in four
episodes which would leave four episodes
remaining for the season this means that
season five will conclude most likely
with the paranormal liberation war arc
which is still ongoing in the manga
right now and I won't give away any
spoilers but from everything we've seen
so far and everything that's still to
come as of making this video I reckon
there is a solid chance that this could
be the best storyline in my academia
like I've been on the edge of my seat
reading this from week to week so
honestly cannot wait in terms of content
the arc will begin with a blast from the
past for Professor Aizawa and a big
development for the villains I can think
of a few good moments where they could
end the season but if they do decide to
go up to chapter 255 you know
following the same pace of season four
then there is only one moment that they
can pick and I think most of you man
greed is you know what I'm talking about
this entire storyline so far has just
had massive reveals pure tension and
ultimately will have serious
consequences for the future of the
series but with that said the vast
majority of it will happen in season six
but season five will have some of it at
least if my calculations are not way off
and yeah that's what we can expect in
season five so I guess the next question
is when can we expect it despite what
you may have heard so far there has been
no official release dates so the real
question is will we get anything in 2020
or will we have to wait till 2021 the
shortest gap we've had between seasons
was seasons two to three in which there
was only a seven-month period before the
season started again however I reckon
that is very unlikely to happen this
time around especially with a certain
problem that is affecting the world
right now it's yet to be seen how that
will affect the schedules of certain
shows only time will tell but for now
I'm being conservative and I'm gonna say
that will likely get season five
beginning in March or April of 2021
that's just a guess and I hope I'm wrong
but greenness takes time people and
right now there's just a lot going on in
the world so I'm thinking we might have
to wait you know quite a long time but
hey if they want to start again in
November 2020 I'm all for it I'm ready
to go anyway guys that was my quick
overview of what we can expect in season
5 and I hope you are all completely
hyped like I am the joint training arc
will be amazing my plan academia that's
like history in the making
the endeavor arc will serve a purpose
and be pretty good and the start of the
walk will just blow your mind especially
if you read vigilantes like I would
recommend before season five starts read
Maya Damian vigilantes let me know which
storyline you guys are most excited to
see in the comment section below and if
you're a manga reader please avoid
putting in spoilers so thanks for
watching guys and peace out